earlier this week there was an attempted
coup in guinea-bissau that's a coastal
state in west africa it's one of the
continent's smallest countries but it's
become a giant in the drugs trade the
cocaine comes from latin america to
guinea bissau and has then moved onwards
to europe
now partly because of the narcotics
trade the country suffers from endemic
corruption and is highly unstable there
have been four military coups and a
number of attempted coups since its
independence from portugal in 1974. this
week's attempt to overthrow president
umaru sisoko in balloon is just the
latest
my next guest once served as prime
minister of guinea bissau
leader of the country's main opposition
party he's also a member of parliament
he ran for president in 2019 but lost
the election welcome to dw news africa
mr pereira i want to begin by asking you
what is your reading about the attempted
coup that we saw in guinea-bissau this
week
thank you for having me
let me say that for our disgrace
guinea bissau has experimented
a number of coup d'etat
and we
we we got some
uh patterns that we look to to see in
that kind of situation that are not
present this time around imagine talking
about two dozen of people if even if
they are armed to try to make a coup
and you have to acknowledge that the the
palace the government palace where
everything has happened
is as 300 meters distance from the main
barrack and they seem not to have
reacted in fact none of the military
structures have taken part on this so
it's a very strange one and everybody is
making the same question
interesting you refer to the fact that
coups and attempted coups are
commonplace um in guinea-bissau why is
there so much political instability in
your country
well i believe that some of the factors
are common to most african countries
the roots of the state
is very weak we failed collectively in
transforming the colonial
state into the national one
while adopting
the western way of life and i would say
this western model
of structure in the state we still
strongly connected and attached to the
grassroots and so we need there's a
choice to be made here either
we
we adopt this this model and we have to
improve certain indicators or we only be
africans and we have to
find a different way of certain things
mr pereira i want to talk to you about
the other big problem
guinea bissau has been dubbed a narco
state because of the rampant cocaine
trafficking through the country
how much is this contributing to the
political instability there
narcotraffic is not
a guinean phenomenon
and
the difference
between what we had in the past and what
we're having now
is
the willingness of the authorities to
work with the
international agencies to combat this
phenomenon either you are opening open
to cooperation or you close
the sovereignty and you claimed
not to cover it
just just to get some clarity there am i
hearing you say that
the the narco state
label is no longer applicable are you
saying uh cocaine trafficking is not as
bad
um because the government is is is
clamping down with the help of
international agencies
no i'm not saying none of those i'm
saying that we are not a norcal state
we have been labeled that because of
prevailing
of
officials that are connected to that
and i believe that to make a difference
is not just a question of the
willingness to fight it right but the
willingness to be open to cooperate with
international uh agencies that have the
capacity and also the structure to help
us impacting that phenomenon
and that was domingo simoes pereira a
politician and opposition leader in
guinea-bissau